women go we're just as horny as men yeah  maybe a lot more requirements ladies  quite a checklist you're like the  goldilocks of dick this guy's too short  this guy's too dumb this guy's just  right guys we'll [ __ ] the porch  and i'm not saying one is better words  just different  i go to the doctor he's like what  happened i was like it was too hot  but look i get it you know it's got to  be tough to be a lady i feel like women  are getting screwed in the orgasm  department i feel like men are having  way more orgasms than women and that  sucks people talk about the wage gap the  orgasm gap is out of control  you gals are getting 77 cents to the  boner  like if a woman had to have an orgasm to  get pregnant they'd be like two people  here  and you get nothing for your orgasm  ladies like if a guy is an orgasm go and  get pregnant carry a baby for nine  months deliver the baby then breastfeed  the baby and all got to do is this  good